السلام
علك
house fre
cost الله
[Silence]
‏pleas
14 ان شاء الله جك الله
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قام
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استووا
واعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف سد الفرج
استو الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
لا يحب الله الجهر
بالسوء من القول الا من ظلم وكان الله
سميعا
عليما ان تبدوا خيرا او تخفوه او تعفوا عن
سوء فان الله كان عفوا قديرا
ان الذين يكفرون بايات الله ويريدون ان
يفرقوا بين الله ورسله
ويقولون ان الذين يكفرون بالله ورسله
ويريدون ان يفرقوا بين الله ورسله
ويقولون ويقولون نؤمن
ببعض ونكفر ببعض ويريدون ان يتخذوا بين
ذلك
سبيلا
اولئك هم الكافرون حقا واعتدنا للكافرين
عذابا
مهينا والذين امنوا بالله ورسله ولم
يفرقوا بين احد منهم
اولئك سوف يؤتيهم
اجورهم وكان الله غفورا
رحيما
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يسالك اهل الكتاب ان تنزل عليهم كتابا من
السماء فقد سالوا موسى اكبر من ذلك فقالوا
ارنا الله جهره فاخذتهم الصاعقه
بظلمهم ثم اتخذوا العجل من بعد ما جاءتهم
بينات فعفونا عن ذلك واتينا موسى سلطانا
مبينا ورفعنا فوقهم الطور بميثاقهم وقلنا
لهم ادخلوا الباب
سجدا وقلنا لهم لا تعدوا في السبت واخذنا
منهم واخذنا
منهم ميثاقا
غليظا فبما قضهم ميثاقهم وكفرهم بايات
الله وقتلهم
الانبياء بغير حق وقولهم قلوبنا
غلف بل طبع الله عليها بكفرهم فلا يؤمنون
الا
قليلا وبكفرهم وقولهم على مريم بهتانا
عظيما وقولهم انا قتلنا المسيح عيسى ابن
مريم رسول
الله وما قتلوه وما صلبوه ولكن شبه لهم
وان الذين اختلفوا فيه لفي شك منه ما لهم
به من علم الا اتباع
الظن وما قتلوه
يقينا بل رفعه الله اليه
وكان الله عزيزا
حكيما وان من اهل الكتاب الا
ليؤمنن به قبل موته ويوم القيامه يكون
عليهم
شهيدا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استووا
اعتدي استو
استو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فبظلم
من الذين هادوا حرمنا عليهم طيبات احلت
لهم وبصدهم عن سبيل الله
كثيرا واخذهم الربا وقد نهوا عنه واكلهم
اموال الناس
بالباطل واعتدنا للكافرين منهم عذابا
اليما لكن الراسخون في العلم منهم
والمؤمنون يؤمنون بما انزل اليك وما انزل
من قبلك والمقيمين
الصلاه
والمقيمين الصلاه والمؤتون الزكاه
والمؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر اولئك سنتيه
اجرا
عظيما انا اوحينا اليك كما اوحينا الى نوح
والنبيين من بعد
ده واوحينا الى ابراهيم واسماعيل واسحاق
ويعقوب
والاسباط وعيسى وايوب
ويونس وعيسى وايوب ويونس وهارون
وسليمان واتينا داوود
زبورا ورسلا قد قصصناهم عليك من قبل ورسلا
لم نقصصهم عل
وكلم الله موسى
تكليما رسلا مبشرين
ومنذرين لئلا يكون للناس على الله حجه بعد
الرسل وكان الله عزيزا
حكيما لكن الله يشهد بما انزل اليك
انزله بعلمه
والملائكه
يشهدون وكفى بالله
شهيدا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
الضالين
امين ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
قد ضلوا ضلالا
بعيدا ان الذين كفروا وظلموا لم يكن الله
ليغفر لهم ولا ليهد م
طريقا الا طريق
جهنم خالدين فيها ابدا وكان ذلك على الله
يسيرا يا ايها الناس قد
جاءكم الرسول بالحق من ربكم فامنوا خيرا
لكم وان تكفروا فان لله ما في السماوات
والارض وكان الله عليما
حكيما يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في دينك في
دينكم ولا
تقولوا يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في دينكم
ولا تقولوا على الله الا
الحق
انما المسيح عيسى ابن مريم رسول الله
وكلمته القاها الى مريم وروح
منه فامنوا بالله ورسله ولا تقولوا ثلاثه
انتهوا خيرا لكم انما الله اله واحد
سبحانه ان يكون له ولد له ما في السماوات
وما في الارض وكفى بالله
وكيلا لن يستنكف المسيح اي يكون عبدا لله
ولا
الملائكه
المقربون ومن
يستنكف عن عبادته ويستكبر فسيحشرهم اليه
جميعا فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فيوفيهم اجورهم
ويزيدهم من
فضله واما الذين ان كفوا واستكبروا
فيعذب عذابا اليما ولا يجدون لهم من دون
الله وليا ولا
نصيرا يا ايها الناس قد
جاءكم برهان من ربكم
وانزلنا اليكم نورا
مبينا فاما الذين امنوا بالله واعتصموا
به فسيدخلهم في
رحمه منه وفضل
ويهديهم ويهديهم اليه
صراطا
مستقيما يستفتونك قل الله يفتيكم في
الكلاله ان امرؤ هلك ليس له ولد وله اخت
فلها نصف ما ترك وهو يرثها ان لم يك كلها
ولد فان كانت اثنت فان كانت اثنتين فلهما
الثلثان مما ترك وان كانوا اخوه رجالا
ونساء فللذكر مثل حظ
الانثيين يبين الله لكم ان تضلوا والله
بكل شيء
عليم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا اوفوا
بالعقود احلت لكم بهيمه الانعام الا ما
يتلى عليكم غير محل الصيد وانتم حرم ان
الله يحكم ما
يريد يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تحلوا شعائر
الله ولا الشهر الحرام ولا الهدي ولا
القلائد ولا
امين البيت الحرام يبتغون فضلا من من ربهم
ورضوانا واذا حللتم فاصطادوا ولا يجرمنكم
شنان قوم ان صدوكم عن المسجد الحرام ان
تعتدوا وتعاونوا على البر والتقوى ولا
تعاونوا على الاثم
والعدوان واتقوا الله ان الله شديد العقاب
حرمت عليكم الميته والدم ولحم الخنزير وما
اهل لغير الله به والمنخنقه والموقوذه
والمترديه
والنطيحه وما اكل السبع الا ما
ذكيتم وما اكل السبع الا ما ذكيتم وما ذبح
على
النصب وان ان تستقسموا
بالازلام ذلكم فسق اليوم يائس الذين كفروا
من دينكم فلا تخشوهم
واخشون اليوم اكملت لكم دينكم واتممت
عليكم نعمتي ورضيت لكم الاسلام دينا فمن
اضر في مخمصه غير متجانف لاثم فان الله
غفور
رحيم يسالونك ماذا احل لهم قل احل لكم
الطيبات وما علمتم من الجوارح مكلبين
تعلمونهن مما علمكم
الله فكلوا مما امسكن عليكم واذكروا اسم
الله عليه واتقوا
الله واتقوا الله ان الله سريع
الحساب اليوم احل لكم الطيبات وطعام الذين
اوتوا الكتاب حل لكم وطعامكم حل لهم
والمحصنات من المؤمنات والمحصنات من الذين
اوتوا
الكتاب والمحصنات من الذين اوتوا الكتاب
من قبلكم اذا اتيتموهن
ان اجورهن محصنين غير مسافحين ولا متخذي
اخدان ومن يكفر بالايمان فقد حبط عمله وهو
في الاخره من
الخاسرين يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا قمتم
الى الصلاه فاغسلوا وجوهكم وايديكم الى
المرافق وامسحوا
برؤوسكم وامسحوا برؤوسكم وارجلكم الى
الكعبين وان كنتم جنبا
فاطهروا وان كنتم مرضى او على سفر او جاء
احد منكم من الغائط او لامستم
النساء فلم تجدوا
ماء فتيم
فتيمموا صعيدا طيبا فامسحوا بوجوهكم
وايديكم
منه ما يريد الله ليجعل عليكم من حرج ولكن
يريد ليطهركم وليتم نعمته عليكم لعلكم
تشكرون واذكروا نعمه الله عليكم وميثاقه
الذي واثقكم به اذ قلتم سمعنا
واطعنا واتقوا الله ان الله عليم بذات
الصدور يا ايها الذين امنوا كونوا قوامين
لله
شهداء
بالقسط ولا يجرمنكم شنان قوم على الا
تعدلوا
ولا يجرمنكم شنان قوم على الا تعدلوا
اعدلوا هو اقرب للتقوى واتقوا الله ان
الله خبير بما
تعملون وعد الله الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات لهم مغفره واجر
عظيم والذين كفروا و كذبوا باياتنا
اولئك اصحاب
الجحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا نعمه
الله عليكم اذ هم قوم ان يبسطوا اليكم
ايديهم فكف ايديهم
عنكم واتقوا الله وعلى الله
فليتوكل المؤمنون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ولقد اخذ الله ميثاق بني
اسرائيل وبعثنا منهم اثني عشر
نقيبا وقال الله اني معكم لئن اقمتم
الصلاه واتيتم الزكاه
وامنتم برسلي وعزرتموهم
واقرضتم الله قرضا حسنا
لاكفرن عنكم
سيئاتكم
لاكفرن عنكم سيئاتكم ولادخل نكم
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار فمن كفر بعد ذلك منكم فقد ضل سواء
السبيل
ما نقضهم ميثاقهم لعناهم وجعلنا قلوبهم
قاسيه
يحرفون يحرفون الكلم عن مواضعه ونسوا حظا
مما ذكروا
به ولا تزال تطلع على
خائنه منهم الا قليلا منهم فاعف عنهم
واصفح
ان الله يحب
المحسنين ومن الذين قالوا انا نصارى اخذنا
ميثاقهم فنسوا حظا مما ذكروا به فاغرينا
بينهم العداوه
والبغضاء الى يوم
القيامه وسوف ينبئهم الله بما كانوا
يصنعون
يا اهل الكتاب قد
جاءكم رسولنا يبين لكم يا اهل الكتاب قد
جاءكم رسولنا يبين لكم كثيرا مما كنتم
تخفون من الكتاب ويعفوا عن
كثير قد
جاءكم من الله نور وكتاب
مبين يهدي به الله من اتبع رضوانه سبل
السلام ويخرجهم من الظلمات الى النور
باذنه ويهديهم الى صراط
مستقيم لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله هو
المسيح ابن مريم قل فمن يملك من الله شيئا
ان اراد ان يهلك المسيح ابن مريم وامه ومن
في الارض
جميعا ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما
بينهما والله على كل شيء
قدير ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما
بينهما يخلق ما
يشاء والله على وهو على كل شيء قدير
والله على كل شيء
قدير ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما بينهما
يخلق ما
يشاء والله على كل شيء
قدير وقالت اليهود والنصارى نحن
ابناء الله
واحباؤه قل فلم يعذبكم بذنوبكم بل انتم
بشر ممن خلق يغفر لمن يشاء ويعذب من
يشاء ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما بينهما
واليه
المصير يا اهل الكتاب قد جاءكم رسولنا
يبين لكم على فتره من الرسل ان تقولوا
ان تقولوا ما
جاءنا من بشير ولا نذير فقد جاءكم بشير
ونذير والله على كل شيء
قدير واذ قال موسى لقومه يا قوم اذكروا
نعمه الله عليكم اذ جعل فيكم
انبياء وجعلكم مل كا
واتاكم واتاكم ما لم يؤت احدا من
العالمين يا قوم ادخلوا الارض المقدسه
التي كتب الله لكم ولا ترتدوا على ادباركم
فتنقلبوا
خاسرين قالوا يا موسى ان فيها قوما جبارين
وانا لن ندخل
حتى يخرجوا
منها فان يخرجوا منها فانا
داخلون قال رجلان من الذين يخافون انعم
الله عليهم ادخلوا عليهم
الباب فاذا دخلتموه فانكم
غالبون وعلى الله فتوكلوا ان كنتم مؤمنين
قالوا يا موسى انا لن ندخلها ابدا ما
داموا فيها فاذهب انت وربك فقاتلا انا
هاهنا
قاعدون قال رب اني لا املك الا نفسي واخي
فافرق بيننا وبين القوم
الفاسقين قال فانها محرمه عليه
اربعين سنه يتيهون في الارض فلا تاس على
القوم
الفاسقين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
بسم
الله بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومنوه ومن تبع باحسان
الى يوم الدين اما بعد
ض رمضان الله سبحانه وتالى سه العمران
وسار الى مغفره من ربكم وجنات عضها
السماوات والارض وت
للمتقين
par
earth pred for
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏so may coule days not found and one the
mother finally find
the sees the and
runs the she
and رول الله عليه
‏think
[Silence]
الله
سبهالى حديث رسول الله ى الله عليه
وسلم بخار مم من صام رمضان ايمان واحتسابا
لقدم من ذن
حديث
حث الجمعه الجمعه رمضان الى رمضان عمره ال
عمره ح حض
الله
[Silence]
رضي الله
عنه اللهم انك عفو تحب العفى فعف عن الله
you are the foring for
us most forging and you love to for
forg so let
make not
let as while are
اللهه
[Silence]
الله
‏then the condition wors the next sal is
and then the cycle continues and
continues and continues and the person
push
into
from
regard
are can are not great allah mercy
soal ask
for الله سانتال
امين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر
وقنا ع وكنا شر فتنه المحيا الممات وكنا
شر فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك
انت السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا مواب
الرحيم صلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الرحمين اللهم امين
اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين استقيم واعتدلوا
استو سو الصف سد الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واتل عليهم نبا بني ادم بالحق اذ
قربا قربانا
اذ قربا قربانا فتقبل من احدهما ولم يتقبل
من
الاخر قال
لاقتلنك قال انما يتقبل الله من
المتقين لئن بسطت الي يدك لتقتلني ما انا
بباسط يدي اليك لاقتلك
اني اخاف الله رب
العالمين اني اريد اني اريد ان
تبوء باثمي واثمك فتكون من اصحاب
النار وذلك
جزاء
الظالمين فطوعت له نفسه قتل اخيه فقتله
فاصبح من
الخاسرين فبعث الله غرابا يبحث في الارض
ليريه كيف يواري سوءه
اخيه قال يا ويلله اعجزت ان اكون مثل هذا
الغراب فواري
اخي فاصبح من
النادمين من اجل ذلك كتبنا على بني
اسرائيل
انه من قتل
نفسا انه من قتل نفسا بغير نفس او فساد في
الارض
فكانما
فكانما قتل الناس
جميعا ومن احياها
فكانما احي الناس
جميعا ولقد
جاءتهم رسلنا
بالبينات ثم
ان ثم ان كثيرا منهم بعد ذلك في الارض
لمسرفون
انما جزاء الذين يحاربون الله ورسوله
ويسعون في الارض
فسادا ويسعون في الارض فسادا ان يقتلوا او
يصلبوا او تقطع ايديهم وارجلهم من
خلاف او ينفوا من الارض ذلك لهم
خزي في
الدنيا ولهم في الاخره عذاب عظيم الا
الذين تابوا من بعد ذل الا الذين تابوا من
قبل ان تقدروا عليهم
فاعلموا فاعلموا ان الله غفور
رحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وابتغوا اليه الوسيله
وجاهدوا وجاهدوا في سبيله لعلكم تفلحون
ان الذين كفروا لو ان لهم ما في الارض
جميعا ومثله معه ومثله معه ليفتدوا به من
عذاب يوم
القيامه ما تقبل منهم ولهم عذاب اليم
يريدون ان يخرجوا من النار وما هم بخ جين
منها ولهم عذاب
مقيم والسارق والسارقه فقطعوا ايديهما
جزاء بما كسبا نكالا من
الله والله عزيز
حكيم فمن تاب من بعد ظلمه واصلح فان الله
يتوب
عليه ان الله غفور
رحيم الم تعلم ان الله له ملك السماوات
والارض يعذب من
يشاء ويغفر لمن
يشاء والله على كل شيء
قدير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الرسول لا يحزنك الذين يسارعون في
الكفر من الذين قالوا امنا
بافواههم من الذين قالوا امنا بافواههم
ولم تؤمن قلوبهم ومن الذين
هادوا ومن الذين هادوا سماع
للكذب
سماعون لقوم اخرين لم
ياتوك يحرفون الكلم من بعد مواضعه
يقولون يقولون ان اوتيتم هذا فخذوه وان لم
تؤتوه
فاحذروا ومن يرد الله فتنته فلن تملك له
من الله شيئا
اولئك الذين لم يرد الله ان يطهر
قلوبهم لهم في الدنيا خزي ولهم في الاخره
عذاب
عظيم
سماعون للكذب
اكالون
للسحت فان
جاؤوك فاحكم بينهم او اع ض عنهم وان تعرض
عنهم فلن يضروك
شيئا وان حكمت بينهم
فاحكم
بالقسط وان حكمت فاحكم
بالقسط ان الله يحب
المقسطين وان حكمت
فاحكم بين هم
بالقسط ان الله يحب
المقسطين وكيف يحكمونك وعندهم التوراه
فيها حكم
الله ثم يتولون من بعد ذلك وما
اولئك
بالمؤمنين
انا انزلنا التوراه فيها هدى
ونور يحكم بها النبيون الذين اسلموا للذين
هادوا
والربانيون والاحبار بما استحفظوا
بما استحفظوا من كتاب الله وكانوا عليه
شهداء فلا تخشوا
الناس واخشون
ولا تشتروا باياتي ثمنا
قليلا ومن لم يحكم بما انزل الله
فاولئك هم
الكافرون وكتبنا عليهم فيها ان النفس
بالنفس والعين بالعين والانف
بالانف والان
ف بالانف والاذن بالاذن
والسن بالسن والجروح
قصاص فمن تصدق به فهو كفاره
له ومن لم يحكم بما انزل الله
فاولئك هم
الظالمون وقفينا على
اثارهم بعيسى ابن مريم
مصدقا مصدقا لما بين يديه من التوراه
واتيناه
الانجيل
واتيناه الانجيل فيه هدى
ونور ومصدقا لما بين يديه من التوراه وهدى
وموعظه
للمتقين وليحكم اهل الانجيل
بما انزل الله
فيه ومن لم يحكم بما انزل الله
فاولئك هم
الفاسقون
وانزلنا اليك الكتاب بالحق مصدقا لما بين
يديه من الكتاب ومهيمنا
عليه فاحكم بينهم
ما انزل الله ولا تتبع
اهواءهم ولا تتبع
اهواءهم عما
جاءك من
الحق لكل جعلنا منكم شرعه
ومنهاجا ولو شاء الله لجعلكم امه واحده
ولكن ليبلوكم فيما اتاكم فاستبقوا
الخيرات الى الله مرجعكم جميعا
فينبئكم بما كنتم فيه
تختلفون وان احكم بينهم بما انزل
الله ولا تتبع
اهواءهم واحذر هم ان يفتنوك عن بعض ما
انزل الله اليك فان تولوا فاعلم انما يريد
الله ان يصيبهم ببعض
ذنوبهم
وان
كثيرا من الناس
لفاسقون افحكم
الجاهليه يبغون
ومن احسن من الله حكما
لقوم
يوقنون الله
اكبر سميع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه ورح
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله الله
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا لا لا تتخذوا
اليهود
والنصارى
اولياء بعضهم
اولياء بعض ومن
يتولهم منكم فانه
منهم ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين فترى الذين في قلوبهم مرض
يسارعون فيهم يقولون نخشى ان تصيبنا
دائره فعسى الله ان ياتي بالفتح او امر من
عنده
فيصبحوا فيصبحوا على ما اسروا في انفسهم
نادمين ويقول الذين امنوا
اهؤلاء الذين اقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم
انهم
لمعكم حبطت اعمالهم فاصبحوا
خاسرين يا ايها الذين امنوا من يرتد منكم
عن دينه فسوف ياتي الله
بقوم فسوف ياتي الله بقوم يحبهم
ويحبونه اذله على المؤمنين عزه على
الكافرين يجاهدون في سبيل الله ولا يخافون
لومه
لائم ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء والله واسع
عليم انما وليكم الله ورسوله والذين
امنوا والذين امنوا الذين يقيمون الصلاه
ويؤتون الزكاه وهم
راكعون ومن يتولى الله رسوله والذين امنوا
فان حزب
الله
فان حزب الله هم
الفائزون فان حزب الله هم
الغالبون يا ايها الذين
امنوا يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا
الذين اتخذوا دينكم نزوا ولعبا من الذين
اوتوا
الكتاب من الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم
والكفار
اولياء واتقوا الله ان كنتم
مؤمنين واذا ناديتم الى
الصلاه اتخذوها
هزوا
ولعبا ذلك بان انهم قوم لا
يعقلون قل يا اهل الكتاب هل تنقمون منا
الا ان امنا بالله وما انزل
الينا هل تنقمون منا الا ان امنا بالله
وما انزل الينا وما انزل من قبل وان ان
اكثركم
فاسقون قل هل انبئكم بشر من ذلك مثوبه عند
الله من لعنه الله وغضب عليه وجعل منهم
القرده
والخنازير وعبد
الطاغوت
اولئك سر مكانا واضل عن عن
سواء
السبيل واذا
جاؤوكم قالوا امنا وقد دخلوا بالكفر وهم
قد خرجوا به والله اعلم بما كانوا
يكتمون وترى كثيرا منهم يسارعون في الاثم
والعدوان واكلهم السحت لبئس ما كانوا
يعملون لولا ينهاهم
الربانيون والاحبار عن قولهم الاثم واكلهم
السحت لبئس ما كانوا
يصنعون وقالت اليهود يد الله
مغلوله غلت ايديهم ولعنوا بما
قالوه بل يداه سوط
تان
ينفق كيف
يشاء
وليزيدن كثيرا منهم ما انزل اليك من ربك
طغيانا
وكفرا والقينا عليهم العداوه
والبغضاء الى يوم
القيامه القينا بينهم العداوه
القيامه كلما اوقدوا نارا للحرب اطفاها
الله ويسعون في الارض فسادا والله لا يحب
المفسدين ولو ان اهل الكتاب امنوا واتقوا
لكفرنا عنهم سيئاتهم
لكفرنا عنهم سيئاتهم ولادخل نهم جنات
النعيم ولو انهم اقاموا التوراه
والانجيل لا وما وما انزل اليهم لاكلوا من
فوقهم ومن تحت
ارجلهم منهم
امه مق
تصده
وكثير منهم
ساء ما
يعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الرسول بلغ ما انزل اليك من
ربك وان لم تفعل فما بلغت
رسالته والله يعصمك من الناس ان الله لا
يهدي القوم
الكافرين قل يا اهل الكتاب لستم على شيء
حتى تقيموا التوراه
والانجيل وما انزل اليكم من
ربكم
وليزيدن كثيرا منهم ما انزل اليك من ربك
طغيانا
وكفرا فلا تاس على القوم
الكافرين ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا
والصابئون والنص صارى من امن
بالله من امن بالله واليوم الاخر وعمل
صالحا فلا خوف
عليهم فلا خوف عليهم ولاهم
يحزنون لقد اخذنا ميثاق بني
اسرائيل
وبعثنا لقد اخذنا ميثاق بني اسرائيل وار
ارسلنا اليهم
رسلا كلما
جاءهم رسول بما لا تهوى
انفسهم فريقا كذبوا وفريقا
يقتلون وحسبوا الا تكون فتنه فعموا وصموا
ثم تاب الله
عليهم ثم تاب الله عليهم ثم عموا وصموا
كثير منهم والله بما يعملون
بصير لا والله بصير بما
يعملون لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله هو
المسيح ابن
مريم وقال المسيح يا بني
اسرائيل ان ان الله ربي
وربكم وقال المسيح ابن مريم يا بني
اسرائيل اعبدوا الله ربي
وربكم انه من يشرك بالله فقد حرم الله
عليه
الجنه وما للظالمين من
انصار ماواه النار وما للظالمين من
انصار لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله ثالث
ثلاثه وما من اله الا اله واحد وان لم
ينتهوا عما يقولون
ليمسن الذين كفروا منهم عذاب
اليم اف يتوبون الى الله
ويستغفرونه والله غفور رحيم ما المسيح ابن
مريم الا رسول قد خلت من قبله الرسل
وامه
صديقه كانا ياكلان
الطعام انظر كيف نبين لهم الايات ثم من
انظر انا
يؤفكون قل اتعبد قل
افتد من دون الله ما لا يملك لكم ضرا ولا
نفعا قل
افتون من دون الله ما لا يملك لكم
ضرا ولا
نفعا والله هو السميع العليم
قل يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في دينكم ولا
تقولوا على قل يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في
دينكم ولا
تتبعوه ولا تتبعوا
اهواء قوم قد ضلوا من قبل واضلوا
كثيرا قل يا اهل الكتاب لا
في دينكم غير الحق ولا تتبعوا
اهواء قوم قد ضلوا من قبل واضلوا كثيرا
وضلوا عن
سواء
السبيل لعن الذين كفروا من بني
اسرائيل على لسان داوود وعيسى ابن مريم
ذلك ما عصوا وكانوا
يعتدون كانوا لا يتناهون عن
منكر
فعلوه لبئس ما كانوا
يفعلون ترى كثيرا منهم يتولون الذين
كفروا لبئس ما قدمت لهم انفسهم ان سخط
الله
عليهم وفي العذاب هم
خالدون ولو انهم ولو كانوا يؤمنون بالله
والنبي وما انزل
اليه وما انزل اليهما اتخذوهم
اولياء
ولكن
كثير منهم فاسقون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الشفعه والوتر ان شاء
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لعن الذين كفروا من بني اسرائيل على
لسان داوود وعيسى ابن مريم ذلك بما عصوا
وكانوا
يعتدون كانوا لا يتناهون عن منكر فعلوه
لبئس ما كانوا
يفعلون ترى كثيرا منهم يتولون الذين كفروا
لبئس ما قدمت لهم انفسهم ان سخط الله
عليهم وفي العذاب هم
خالدون ولو كانوا يؤمنون بالله والنبي وما
انزل اليه اتخذوهم
اولياء
ولكن
كثيرا منهم
فاسقون الله اكبر
سم الله لمن
حمده الله
اكب الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين ارايت الذي يكذب بالدين فذلك الذي
يدع
اليتيم ولا يحض على طعام
المسكين فويل
للمصلين الذين هم عن صلاهم
ساهون الذين هم يراءون
ويمنعون
الماعون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اك الله
اكب الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا
فيه كما تحب وترضاه مل السماء والارض ومل
ما بينهما ومل ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل
الثناء والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك
عبد اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سم ع
الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام يا حي يا قيوم يا بديع السماوات
والارض ويا رحمن الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد
عظم حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت
ف لك الحمد فلك الحمد يا ربنا ملء السماء
وملء
الارض اللهم لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرته
ولا مريضا الا شفيته ولا ميتا من اموات
المسلمين الا رحمته ولا مبتلا الا عفوت
ولا مبتلا الا
عافيته ولا
ضالا الا هديته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا
دينا الا قضيته ولا حاجه من حوائج الدنيا
هي لنا خير ولك رضا الا قضيتها بفضلك
ورحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار
اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب
ابائنا قب ابائنا وامهاتنا
وازواجنا واخواننا
واصحابنا
ومشايخنا ومن لهم حق
علينا اللهم اعتق رقابنا جميعا من النار
اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم وتب
علينا انك انت التواب الرحيم اللهم اعز
الاسلام والمسلم لمين اللهم اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين واعلي بفضلك رايتي الحق والدين
المبين وانصر المستضعفين من المسلمين في
كل مكان وانصر المسلمين المستضعفين في كل
مكان في غزه
والسودان وفي كل
مكان يا رحيم يا رحمن اللهم اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اللهم انا نسالك من الخير كله عاجله
واجله ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم ونعوذ بك
من الشر كله عاجله
واجله
ما ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم نسالك من كل
خير سالك منه عبدك ورسولك محمد وعبادك
الصالحون ونعوذ بك من كل شر استعاذك منه
عبدك ورسولك محمد وعبادك
الصالحون اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم اجمعين
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله الله
[Silence]
ا